this is the peregrine falcon one of
nature's fold as predators for thousands
of years humans have admired its
powerful wings and fiery spirit but one
quality above all sets this bird of prey
apart when it comes to raw speed no
creature on earth can match it
commercial pilot Ken Franklin raises and
studies Falcons to see how they live and
how they move what characterizes a pair
involvin is it's pure ability to hunt at
high speed in the open-air space the
more that I was involved in flight with
furs and started seeing their speed the
more I wanted to I really was driven
just to be basically on wing with them
but experts can't agree on the
peregrines top speed to answer that
question
ken assembles a team of specialists and
a very special Falcon named frightful
he'll test your speed with a lead
weighted lure that he'll release as he
dives
with her a tiny computer like those used
by skydivers is clipped on to feather
shafts just under frightful x' tail
covets ken is confident it won't affect
her performance the cessna strains in
the thin air at 15,000 feet although
wild falcons may reach this altitude
this is the highest frightful has ever
been in her life frightful is released
at 12,000 feet she goes into her dive
after 10 seconds she's going 120 miles
an hour can releases the Lord 21 seconds
frightful ships into hyperdrive
that's what Ken's been looking for she
shifts her shape to slip through the
airs molecules
forty-three seconds she catches the door
pulls out of her dive at 3,000 feet and
heads home
moments later Ken shoots snaps open it
looks like a perfect flight the verdict
is in frightful has broken her own
record and Ken still doesn't know how
much faster she can go 183 miles now
aerodynamically they are the incredible
contortionist this is like karate in the
air and what they do to hyper streamline
and then when they achieve highest
speeds how they hold it blew this away
one week later frightful was clocked at
an astonishing 242 miles an hour